(Audience): Good Morning, John, it's Friday!
(Audience cheering)
(Upbeat music)
Would anybody like a breakfast burrito?
There's a thing here. I don't know what it-
Is it cheaper for bands?
[oh], it's outside is this the thing?
(door creaking)
Oh, it's outside.
(Katherine): Well you got to follow the footsteps
(Hank): Is this The Thing?
(Man): No.
(Hank): Ok.
(Man): I don't think you can broadcast what The Thing is.
It'll just be a reaction video to The Thing.
Do you like this?
I like The Thing.
Made in Constantinople, or was it Istanbul?
Ok, another door and now we're in another person's yard.
Here's another shed!
Is the thing in her-oh, I think The Thing is in here.
Is this The Thing?
Here lies The Thing.
Ohhh.
(wheezing laughter)
Ooooh.
(All): Whoa!
(All): What? Whoa! Oh No! Who-ho-ho What? Seriously?
(All): What is that?
(All): Ew, Eughhh
(Katherine): Is that real?
There aren't any informational placards, about it, at all.
Well, it's here, so it's real.
Right, it does exist.
(Katherine) It's real. Yeah. I'm looking at The Thing.
(door squeaking)
My curiousity is unsatisfied.
Some things aren't meant to be known, like
for example
For example, I guess, The Thing.
(Fast guitar playing)
(loud stomping echo)
We got a melted Hershey Bar.
Just, like, make a little hole
Suck it all out!
Wanna try?
Nope!
(Slow, calm music)
(music starts to pick up)
(faster, upbeat music)
We have regrets.
(sigh)
It's been uphill for a long time. (exhausted)
(guitar music)
(guitar and saxophone music)
Oh, last show is over!
There's a ladder here, I don't know where it goes, I'm gonna try to go up.
(Crowd chattering in background)
I don't feel like risking it.
Nope. Just cool lighting up here.
It's not-not built for people with my disposition.
This was really fun.
So many great shows, so many great people.
(sigh)
I really like our community.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.